こんにちははじめシャツノーです皆さん年末は
湯を見てそしてますかそうでバッといえば紅白歌合戦でございます
すぎて今回ですねなんと含む5を見ている紅白ば生産とその後させていただくことに
なりました
ありがとうございますね
違った心ということで今回ですね今年で66回にあるんですけどもう60くらいから
ですね
明治シンボルということができましてこちらになります
実にシンプルですどうですかいつでも可愛らしいだと思います
富士山腰が遺産に登録されたのでそういうことがあってなく実際の音と思ってるんです
か
夏じゃのう
練習ボール今回支えたとかですねはいえさんの安部誠治さんということでとてもマヤ
シーズンが実績なしボロになっておりましたが音階ですね僕の動画では富士山せっかく
撮っているので
紅白七瀬出版
紅白歌合戦徳仁さん外かけてみてこちらは今回はあと白の紅白マッド出る実装すみよう
と思います
いかにももうかっこいいですね
では早速 ao 早速事故と思います良い子とかも言っては早速作っていこうと思い
ます
三角旗を待つ者の2トップが初めになるのでこの辺度ちょっと紅白か見分けつかない
感じになってるんですけど
会津会さんてこ作るのから始まります
移行してをつなげればもう多分三角になるともう声感じです
図5 a 患者さん客をたくさん作って言ってもはく紅白幸福ぺ
-2紅白紅白付-2幸福服和服-21
ウェイウー do
お気づきだろうか赤と白の高さが微妙に違うこれでは紅白購読できないのね方向高校
白白白広告白斑価格
はい
このような多く頭使う安定化がなかったのでちょっと
一方この床をつくってからおいていきます10
です
お兄さんにしろのアレを引きますぅカーを
パパって言えばゆ的ですごい
意外な数との闘いになってきた誇りこれだけなんちょっといるかと思っ
なツアーも従い前よく見たらん
なぜならもうちょっとちょっと怖くなってきたと思ったよりちょっと難しそう
高
保育は歪んでますからな感じですよあと3つあと3つずつまたまたまたまたやっちまっ
て作ってみますマダマダマダマダ妻だめだ
まだまだ出るまですっもうずっとつを築く
re ん
pou dou dou
ています
はいと言うでここまでなんとか
祭礼したんですけどもちょっとこういうちょっと補強とだしてなんとか素早いいく砂を
使うと思って待っちょっともう最後でキスなんてやってみましょう
そうそうですからね
いい
me ん
モール
ぜひ立ってきた是非試しいただいた官兵衛
ええええええ
はい時で完成
今回何度ですねー
th
綺麗になりましたね今回ですね24dec の深夜今回の紅白歌合戦の pr 番組
紅白宣伝部という番組に僕肇社長と鹿議員さんが失礼しますありがとうございます紅白
戦前夫の詳しい情報は動画説明欄にありますけどチェックしてください
ケニー4日06:00
なくてはなりませんん
ちょっとキレイになっちゃったけどまあ完成してよかったです
じゃん